hey thanks for joining us I'm Ali
and I'm Kelsey we're both Google Cloud
engineers and today we'll be talking
about how adopting customer work
policies allows customers to speed up
the process for authoring guard rails
we'll be running through a short
scenario to demonstrate how this works
in this video I'll be playing the role
of
a Security administrator for pistach.io
a nuts to service and completely fake
company
and I'll be playing the role of
myself
hey there thanks for meeting with me I'm
a Security administrator and
representative of pistache.io have you
heard of it we're very passionate about
delivering necessary service to our
customers so naturally I'm a bit anxious
that our gke clusters are not being
properly encased with a secure hard
outer shell
Kelsey Google has great perimeter
Security in its data centers with
electric fences surveillance and
everything you yeah but I would also
prefer our gke clusters to only deploy
authorized images meaning we should only
allow images to be sent to gke if
they've passed out of Security checks
and are validated as safe can we get an
org policy for that uh-huh this question
sounds familiar remember when you had
asked me the same thing last year at
that time it would have taken roughly
six months but don't worry I've got
great news as of today Google Cloud
supports the creation of custom work
policies directly in fact you can create
your own gke customer policy before this
video is even over
whoa that's quick how exactly
well let's do it right now sounds good
with custom org policies you can Define
your own constraint based on the rest
representation of a cloud resource so to
secure our GK container images I need to
find the corresponding attribute in the
GK cluster rest resource uh-huh oh there
it is binary authorization nice now
let's create a custom constrained yaml
file for that attribute don't you need
to tell gcp to use this custom
constraint yeah yes exactly use the
gcloud org policies set custom
constraint command to make your custom
policy go live wait I should probably
tell our employees who we call them
pistachio nuts before we enforce this
policy just in case
yes this policy can be disruptive in
your organization however soon you will
have the ability to set the policy in
dry run mode which is essentially an
audit only mode the audit logs report on
possible violations rather than actually
blocking unauthorized images so with dry
run you can be sure that the employees
the pistachio knots will continue
launching those nuts non-stop when the
policy actually goes live that's sick so
this policy won't disrupt our pistachio
delivery service not at all
to learn more about customer policies
check out the documentation the link
will be in the description
[Music]
[Music]